The next step is to add
a second horizontal stack view.
So that it can hold a chipmunk and
Darth Vader sound effect buttons.
With the main storyboard file open and
the play sounds viewer controller
selected, open the main storyboard file,
and select the play
sounds view controller.
Let's search for
stack view here in the objects library.
Drag a horizontal stock for
you from the object library
into the document outline.
Make sure that it's embedded
inside the vertical stack view,
our outer most stack view
here in the document outline.
The easiest way is to drag it above
the first horizontal stack view and
reorder them here in
the document outline.
Your document outline should look
similar to what you see here.
One more thing, with this new
horizontal stuff you selected,
change the distribution setting in
the attribution specter to fill equally.
Xcode may be warning you
about auto layout constraints
because this new horizontal stack view
does not have any UI elements inside it.
A search for buttons here,
I'm going to drag one under
our Neo horizontal stack view.
In the actually inspector I'm
going to remove the text for
this buttons title and
changes image to chipmunk.
I'm going to rename it here in
a document outline, the chipmunk button.
We need to follow the same steps
to create the Darth Vader button.
We'll drag a button from the object
library underneath the new
horizontal stack view,
remove the text from the title and
this time change
the image to Darth Vader.
We need to make sure that these
buttons are on the same level.
That is, they're inside
this horizontal stack view.
We can do that by toggling
this disclosure triangle here.
That was easy, now we have four buttons
in this view perfectly aligned and
we have not had to add a single
auto layer constraint.